greetings and salutations suck you
[ __ ] it's time for an all-new
breakdown series and this time we're
checking out the chilling Adventures of
Sabrina or chaos for short so prepare to
take the path of night and join me as we
dive in the first thing we see is this
insanely kick-ass title sequence they're
done in the style of the Archie horror
comics on which the show is based at one
point you can even see Archie himself in
the corner here the logo is also pretty
sick with the upside-down cross for the
tea and the pentagram and there are then
we're immediately confronted with the
big dilemma facing Sabrina by her 16th
birthday she has to choose between the
witch world of her family or the human
world of her friends but for now she's
just chilling with her boyfriend Harvey
kinkle love that name at a screening of
George our Romero's Night of the Living
Dead
after the film Sabrina is joined by her
friends Suzy Putnam and Rosalyn Walker
before bumping into miss ward well one
of the teachers at Baxter hi Sabrina
invites her to doctor services a local
hangout spot to discuss the movie in
Greek mythology Cerberus was often
referred to as the Hound of Hades a
multi-headed dog that guards the gates
of the underworld to prevent the dead
from leaving but Wardwell passes and
sabrina tells her friends that she feels
sorry for her living all alone in that
spooky house miss ward well jams too bad
moon rising when someone runs in front
of her car she gets out to investigate
in her eyes wide net who she sees a
young woman looked like she just went
swimming in a swamp she picks her up
calling her a poor creature and that
she'll clean her up and give her to dr.
Saperstein tomorrow and here is dr.
services you can make out the
three-headed dog here Sabrina and the
gang discussed the meaning of the Romero
film the collapse of the nuclear family
kind of like how Sabrina's family is far
from a traditional nuclear family we see
Spellman mortuary where Sabrina lives
next to a pet cemetery because that's
just cool harvey gives her a necklace
and tells her he loves her also
shout-out to these badass pumpkins in
the back ward well prepares some tea for
swamp girl and we get a glimpse of a
cross in the background suggesting that
Wardwell might be religious notice the
use of the specific camera lens which
blurs the outer edges of the frame
suggesting something dreamlike or
supernatural it also happens later on
when Sabrina enters the forest
the young girl tells Wardwell that the
forest attacked her and we learn a brief
history of Greendale and how there was a
witch hunt back in 1692
thirteen witches were hung in the forest
and their angry spirits haunt it to this
day you can see these witches later on
in the show when Sabrina eats the Apple
Wardwell is Greendale's unofficial town
historian but it looks like not for long
as the young girl stabs her in the neck
with a pair of scissors she seemingly
possesses Wardwell telling the Dark Lord
shall deliver Sabrina you see Sabrina is
the offspring of a male warlock and
mortal woman which is a sacred violation
of which law
Sabrina wakes up and we see she's four
days away from her 16th birthday which
coincidentally enough takes place on
Halloween her 16th is also referred to
as the dark baptism a sacred ritual
which celebrates a young witch venturing
into adulthood making a sacred pact with
the Dark Lord by signing their name in
his book she looks at an old photo of
her mother and father who will learn a
bit more about later but the moment is
ruined by a bat that smashes through the
window a bad omen we're then given this
title Tuesday October 28th of this year
which suggests we may be flashing back
and forth through time in this series
Sabrina has breakfast with her two aunts
Zelda and Hilda and her cousin Ambrose
the necromancer with whom she lives with
they're all excited for her upcoming
dark baptism she must also pick a
familiar familiars our goblins who have
taken the shape of animals to serve
their witch masters Sabrina doesn't want
to pick one out of the council approved
registry rather use the Craigslist for
demons the demon omec on
she's also chosen her baptismal name
Edwina Diana to honor her mother Diana
and father Edwin burying the bat she
expresses her doubts about becoming a
witch to Ambrose we learned that when
she gets baptized she'll have to move
away from her friends to cultivate her
gifts at the academy of unseen arts an
academy where her father was once
headmaster Ambrose just doesn't
understand what she's going through he
was born a full witch and never had to
say goodbye to his friends not to
mention he's been under house arrest for
75 years forbidden from leaving the
grounds my guesses we'll learn about
what he did in upcoming episodes
Sabrina ventures into the woods to calm
the spirits of the forest looking for a
familiar the spell she uses refers to
the relationship between witch and
familiar as one
equals not master and servant she's
visited by Resident Academy of unseen
arts bullies prudence Dorcas and Agatha
who warned her if a half-breed like her
comes to the Academy she may face the
same fate as her parents they put a
blood curse on her witch Aunt Hilda
helps diagnose later on in the episode
sabrina rushes to school to wash away
the hex and finds susie sobbing in the
locker apparently for football players
pulled up her shirt to see if she was a
girl or not the same for football
players we see briefly snickering at the
movie theater
Sabrina rushes to principal Hawthorne
but he's a total dick and refuses to do
anything about it
suggesting that Susie should find
another school after asking Harvey for
his help Sabrina is interrupted by
makeover Wardwell who is now possessed
by a powerful witch saying she can help
in her office notice the dolls just like
the ones Wardwell collected in her house
Sabrina wants to teach Hawthorne a
lesson and Wardwell gives her an in he's
terrified of spiders at lunch Sabrina
devises a plan to start an anti white
patriarchy Club and Roz suggests they
throw a party for her birthday but she
has plans she can't tell them about the
dark baptism as an ominous raven watches
over them The Raven is stole aswer
dwells familiar and we learned Wardwell
has been sent to do the Dark Lord's
bidding and Hilda tell Zelda a young boy
has been stabbed and the parents have
called the mortuary Zelda thinks this is
perfect timing since human blood is
needed for the dark baptism ceremony
Harvey tries to convince Sabrina to do
something for her birthday but she drops
a bomb on him telling him that she's
moving to a boarding school in
Connecticut but Harvey is upset and
rightly so she's being shady and hiding
something from him but on the other hand
she can't tell him she's a witch sabrina
takes harvey to the forest telling him
this is where she'll be reborn during
her dark baptism telling him that she's
half witch that she'll have to renounce
any and all meaningful connections to
mortals
Harvey's and having it thinking she just
wants to get rid of him after telling
her he loves her but Sabrina fearing
their last few days together will be
ruined puts a non-consensual spell on
him so that he forgets everything that
just happened bad Sabrina Sabrina's a
heart-to-heart with Ambrose telling him
what happened and that she wishes she
could just bring her friends with her
she also wants help with his spell to
take care of the principal she tells her
aunts about the girls
the Academy hexing her Zelda says
they're just jealous since she's the
daughter of a high priest and reinforces
her need for a familiar they help in
defending against such attacks sabrina
then confronts her aunts about how her
parents died questioning if it was
really an accident but Zelda's firm
saying that it was a tragic plane crash
while on their way to the Vatican in the
bath she receives a flashback of her
mother and father she chases after them
to find two children one normal likely
her and the other with Hobbit feet this
is super interesting because it could
mean many things could be another bad
omen symbolism of her being half dark
and half light or that she potentially
has a sibling and if it's the sibling
thing the other child could have
something to do with why her parents
were off to the Vatican notice how her
father here holds a suitcase like
they're headed off somewhere Ambrose and
Sabrina perform a spell to scare
principal Hawthorne and judging by the
look on his face it works very well
Sabrina ventures back to her room to
find a spirit has heard her call from
the woods and taken the shape of a cat
it's her new familiar Salem and aunt
Zelda still can't get over why Sabrina
chose a feral one instead of one bred
for service Salem named himself that
leading me to think that he could be a
spirit descendant of one of the men or
women who was killed in Salem during the
witch trials that could be a real cool
twist Sabrina asks if she can delay her
dark baptism so that she can have more
time to start this club and work out the
Harvey situation since they've taken
things to the next level Zelda almost
has a heart attack thinking she's been
defiled since which law states an
officiant must be a virgin
they must save themselves for the Dark
Lord moving forward we learned that a
witch's powers come from the Dark Lord
in exchange for signing his dark book
she gets in a fight with Zelda unsure
why she has to give everything up in her
life in order to be part of the Church
of the night but Zelda is firm Sabrina
will be a member of the Church of the
night and that's final
Ambrose tells her that if she decides
not to take the path of the knight her
powers will fade and suggests in order
for her to make sure she's making the
right decision to get her hands on a
malum malice an apple the fruit of
knowledge which whispers secrets to you
it could show you the future illuminate
either the path of light or path of
night she'll first need to find an old
apple tree
but look at the Raven Ward Wells
familiar watching over the conversation
the raven tells ward well of Sabrina's
plan and we learned that if Sabrina
doesn't choose the path of the night the
Lord of Darkness will not be pleased
Sabrina and Roz asked to get their club
approved and learning that Hawthorne
didn't come in to work receive their
approval from vice principal Glover they
decide to call the group Wicca women's
intersectional cultural and creative
Association but wick is also a term used
to describe pagan witchcraft and come on
which high school doesn't have a roaring
fireplace Sabrina is called in to see
miss ward well who tries to get more
information out of her more importantly
she asks which apple patch she's going
to after school Ambrose takes care of
the dead body that was stabbed and
something catches his attention he calls
in the ants and they find out the
birthmark on his arm is actually a
witch's mark they can tell because it
doesn't bleed this is especially
concerning because it could mean a witch
hunter is on the loose Harvey and
Sabrina go apple picking and Sabrina
conveniently finds a sign to the oldest
tree around whoever shall have to travel
through the hay maze to get it again we
see the blurred edges as she enters
hinting that something supernatural is
around Sabrina is attacked by a
scarecrow I mean I just hate it when
that happens but manages to escape
Wardwell controls a puppet scarecrow
which looks like she's made out of the
materials used to create the other dolls
found in the house and it looks like
Sabrina's toast when she's saved by
Salem in spirit form you can make it out
here of course when she goes to check on
him he's back in cat form and the
Scarecrow has deflated Wardwell is not
pleased she arrives at the old tree in
Salem hisses as she pulls the only red
apple she eats it and it turns rotten
showing her a vision from the past which
is hanging from the tree blood on her
hands and a creature which is likely the
Dark Lord in the comics you can see a
similar monster referred to as the Dark
Lord here she spits out the Apple and is
transported back to the real world
Sabrina arrives home explaining she's
made her decision about the baptism when
she's called into the living room by her
Aunt Hilda
someone is there for her this is Faustus
Blackwood the high priest of the Church
of the night the same position her
father once held faustus is an
interesting name deriving from an old
German legend in which the protagonist
Faust makes a pact with the devil this
makes sense since Hilda tell
that the high priest is the Dark Lord
Satan's representative on earth the
episode ends with him telling her that
she's been chosen asking what he can do
to convince her to take the path of
night and with only two days left until
her dark baptism it'll be interesting to
see what he has up his sleeve
I think this show is pretty damn fun but
I want to hear what you guys think
should I keep doing these episode
breakdowns or should I do one big video
at the end that kind of handles all of
them leave a comment below and as always
make sure to LIKE and subscribe with the
Belon we'll see you here for episode 2